Major breaking news as the anti-gunners
in the District of Columbia scramble in
a panic in a desperate attempt to unwind
the decision of Benson versus the
District of Columbia. Benson versus the
United States dealing with the DC Court
of Appeals overturning, shutting down of
declaration of being unconstitutional,
the magazine ban of DC. huge win in the
Benson case. And now DC is scrambling
trying to save the law, trying to save a
major gun control law because they know
if they don't do it, it's going to get
wiped out nationwide by the US Supreme
Court. A petition for onbank reviewed in
the DC Court of Appeals has just been
filed by the District of Columbia. I
suspect that the Trump Department of
Justice will oppose this and I'm not
sure this petition will go anywhere. But
let's break down their arguments and
what's going to happen next in this
important case of Benson versus United
States dealing with the DC magazine ban
for basically magazines that hold more
than 10 rounds. We'll talk about it when
we come right back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
four box of D. Proud American gun owner,
constitutional attorney, member of the
United States Supreme Court Barn, and
I'm proud to say the top voice of the
Second Amendment in back-to-back years.
Thank you. 2025 and 2026 Gundy's awards.
All right, before we talk about this
important submission by the District of
Columbia and the anti-guners trying to
undercut and destroy that huge Second
Amendment win by the DC Court of Hills
that ruled that it does indeed violate
the Second Amendment right of the people
to keep your arms if you ban magazines
that hold more than 10 rounds, let's say
that is the holding of Benson versus the
United States. Remember the Donald
Trump, Pam Bondi, and Janine Piro
Department of Justice came in and filed
a huge brief in September in support of
the right to keep and bear arms and said
that guess what? The DC ban on magazines
that hold more than 10 rounds are
unconstitutional under the second
amendment. And in a two to1 decision
just a few weeks ago, the DC court of
appeals agreed with the Trump Bondi
Janine Piro Department of Justice and
said yes in fact a magazine that b
magazine ban uh of any sort violates the
second amendment. But before we get into
those details, I want to remind everyone
that if you're out there in Arizona next
week for the gun owners of America
event, I will be the keynote speaker on
the Friday night activist dinner. So, if
you're going to be out there in the
Phoenix, Arizona area uh next week, make
sure you swing on by the Gun Owners of
America event. And if you have a chance,
stop by and see my speech as the keynote
speaker of the Gun Owners of America
annual activist dinner. Check it out out
there. Okay, so let's turn back to this
Benson case. Now, again, as I predicted,
the DC is seeking onbunk review. I don't
know if it's going to fly for them
because over the last decade or two,
they've only heard maybe one onbunk case
a year. very very rare and the cases
they hear on bach tend to be very
specific criminal procedural issues like
how do you pick a jury in a criminal
case? How do you vaude deer prospective
jurors? You know these sort of very
nerdy criminal procedure type cases uh
to clarify things for the DC trial
courts in criminal cases as tends to be
what they address. Here though, you have
a substantive constitutional right
protected by federal law. And needless
to say, by virtue of the fact of our
side winning, this uh case of Benson
versus the United States and having this
criminal conviction conviction for
possessing magazines of Homer in the 10
rounds thrown out, which was the relief
requested by the Trump Department of
Justice in a brief in this case.
By virtue of this big win for us, this
creates a split of authority that
historically has been a basis for the
United States Supreme Court to take up a
particular legal issue because the DC
Court of Appeals is the highest court,
the highest court in the District of
Columbia system, not to be confused with
the United States Court of Appeals for
the DC Circuit, which is kind of the
federal circuit court,
separate kind of court system. One is
the federal system. The DC Court of
Appeals is kind of the equivalent of the
state system. Although DC is a district
and not a state, you get the point. But
the DC Court of Appeals by ruling in
favor of the Second Amendment has
created a split of authority in America
over whether or not magazines can be
banned consistent with the Second
Amendment. This is freaking out the
anti-gunners because by creating this
clear circuit split, you have now just
created a platform, a hook if you will,
for the United States Supreme Court to
take up and decide the question of
whether magazines at home more than 10
rounds are protected by the Second
Amendment and or can they be banned? The
answer is obvious. We will win that
case. The only reason why we won't win
this case is the Supreme Court doesn't
take it. Historically, the reason why
the Supreme Court hasn't taken cases
like this is because there's no circuit
split or there's no split of authority.
Why is there no split of authority?
Historically, we know why. Because the
only states in America, the only
jurisdictions in America that adopt
these insane whackadoodle anti-gun laws
like banning AR-15s, banning
semi-automatic rifles, banning magazines
that hold more than 10 rounds are in
these deep blue states that are overseen
by federal appellet courts that are
packed to the gills
with judges who have been appointed and
blessed by those same deep blue
politicians, those same deep blue US
senators that are elected from those
deep blue jurisdictions. So when you
have an AR-15 ban case or semi-automatic
rifle ban case or magazine ban case
going up, let's say in the US Court of
Appeals for the Second Circuit in New
York City, you're going to get a bunch
of judges that have been blessed by like
Senator Chuck Schumer. Same with
California, same with Washington State,
same with Chicago. The same blue state
politicians that passed the anti-gun
laws are the same blue state politicians
that picked the judges or at least are
highly involved with picking judges even
in the federal system. So of course you
have uniformity historically that all
these blue state judges affirm and
confirm that there is no second
amendment right to possess AR-15s to
possess a semi-automatic rifle to
possess magazines hold them in 10 rounds
and so on and so on. But now, and of
course, in contrast, you never get an
AR-15 bank case or a magazine bank case
arising out of Louisiana, out of Texas,
out of Florida, right? Because they
don't pass the laws. And because they
don't pass these insane laws, there's no
basis to challenge them in front of
originalist conser constitutional
conservatives. So, you never get another
side. You never get a split of
authority. So, now that you have a split
of authority here, thanks to the DC
Court of Appeals, you've created a
situation for the Supreme Court to take
a magazine ban case. And that will go
terribly for the anti-gunners if the
court takes it. And that is why we see
this desperate attempt. And this brief,
by the way, in terms of the quality, uh,
although the arguments are no good in my
view, the quality of the brief is quite
high, which tells me that I suspect the
DC attorneys probably got some real
support and really put in some real
effort here to try to get the DC court
appeals to rehear this case on bond.
Just to jog your memory, this was a two
to one decision in Benson versus the
United States. Big win for the Second
Amendment. So what has just occurred?
The lawyers for the District of Columbia
have just sought a filed a petition for
onbank review. They are begging the
entirety of the DC Court of Appeals, of
which I think right now there's about
eight or nine of the judges there. They
want the entire DC Court of Appeals to
grant onbunk review and to decide uh
this case. and they want them to
overturn the three judge panel ruling
thereby eliminating the split of
authority. That is the goal of DC and
I'm sure every anti-gun group in America
is praying and praying to the extent
they pray at all. I suspect uh but they
are praying lighting candles or doing
incense or smoking peyote whatever they
do to their gods uh or lack thereof.
They are desperately hoping that the DC
court appeals grants onbunk review and
overturns and reverses this three judge
panel decision in favor of the second
amendment. Now with that said, let's
turn to some of the arguments made uh in
this brief arguing that the DC court
appeals should grant reharing on Bach
and hear the case with all judges on the
on the DC court appeals. Let's look at
some of the arguments. These arguments
for those of you who litigate these
cases, a lot of these arguments are
going to start to ring very similar to
the sorts of things we see in the
federal system in federal cases
involving these issues, which is telling
me there may be cross talk going on
here. I suspect there is. I don't know
for a fact. I'm just guessing, but
there's probably cross talk between the
anti-gun groups in America and the DC
Attorney General's office because this
is now a very big deal with national
implications. So, let's begin with how
they open up their brief. The DC Court
of Appeals should grant reharing onbank
to address several issues of exceptional
importance raised by this appeal. In its
firstofakind decision that creates a
conflict with six federal courts of
appeals, the division struck down the DC
prohibition on the possession of large
capacity magazines, LCMS, magazines with
a capacity of more than 10 bullets. This
law prevents gun users from continuously
firing between 12 and 100 rounds without
reloading. The law thus aims to stop a
lone shooter from killing swaths of
people without pause. That's a key
thing, without pause. while still
allowing law-abiding gun owners to
defend themselves. It goes on to say,
"The division's decision cries out for
onbunk review." The division struck down
as unconstitutional, a critical
long-standing public safety law, which
alone warrants rehearing on bonk. But
here, the division's decision conflicts
with the reasoning of every appellet
court in the nation to have considered
the issue. That includes the DC circuit,
which just two years ago held the
district, the District of Columbia's
prohibition on LSCMs as likely
constitutional, cited Hansen versus DC.
Okay, let's start with the problems
right there. To begin with, they talk
about a split of authority, which is
exactly what I said. This creates a
split of authority. So, they're
admitting that, which is very good for
us. But then they talk about how these
six federal courts of appeals have come
out on the other side. And again, what
did I just explain? Why are these six
courts of appeals
come out to say that you can ban
magazines that hold more than 10 rounds?
And what courts are they relying on? And
where are they based? Oh, I don't know.
You've got the Ninth Circuit out of San
Francisco. Blue jurisdiction.
You've got the Seventh Circuit out of
Chicago, blue jurisdiction. You've got
the Second Circuit out of New York City,
blue jurisdiction.
You've got the First Circuit out of
Boston, blue jurisdiction. You've got
the Fourth Circuit out of Virginia and
Maryland, blue jurisdiction. You've got
the DC case in Hansen, which is
distinguishable. We'll get to that in a
second. But the DC Hansen case, blue
jurisdiction.
You see the trend? Again, this is how
the anti-gunners play the game. They get
these precedents. They get these laws in
terrible anti-gun jurisdictions. They
get anti-gun judges to rubber stamp
these laws. And then they turn around in
a case like here in Benson and say,
"Look, every court that ever considered
this question has ruled that guns are
bad and the second amendment is bad.
We're right." See,
it's hoie. It's hoie because the other
half of the country never gets second
amendment decisions in their federal
court systems because there's no law
enacted in the first place that's insane
for there to even be a legal challenge.
So there you have it. That's why they
keep saying, "Look at all these other
courts that have decided the question,
but the only other courts that have
decided the question are in these deep
blue jurisdictions that rubber stamp gun
control laws, no matter what they are.
Seabball, Hitball." Now, beyond that,
there's another terrible mistake in my
view that DC's made. If you look at
pages, double I and triple I, you're
like, "Mike, Mark, why are we looking at
pages double I and triple I?" Look at
the table of authorities. They have at
the bottom an asterisk. And that
asterisk says, "Authorities upon which
we chiefly rely are marked with
asterisks." Fine. Guess what, folks?
They they do not bark with an asterisk
DC versus Heller. Think about that. The
case decided by the Supreme Court on an
armsband question
is DC versus Heller. They cite to DC
versus Heler, but they do not chiefly
rely upon it because even though that is
the decision, as I point out repeatedly
in the Harvard Journal of Law and Public
Policy, Heler is the decision that tells
courts how to decide arms ban cases and
the historical tradition that gives rise
to possible arms bans, which is the
dangerous unusual test.
They want to here in DC, they literally
say we're relying on the DC Court of
Appeal decision in Hansen versus DC,
which was a preliminary injunction case,
not even on a final judgment. They're
relying on that precedent instead of the
US Supreme Court president of Heler.
Total BS.
But that's what they're doing to try to
confuse the issue. I don't think it's
going to work, but that's what they're
trying to do. The other funny thing they
say here is they say you need to grant
bonk review because uh otherwise they
claim that the division has knocked out
a nearly century old statute
and that's a longstanding statute. Okay,
let's think about this for a moment. How
good is that argument? The Supreme Court
in the year of our Lord 2022 knocked out
the Sullivan law that was enacted in the
early part of the 20th century by New
York State. It went byebye.
Do you think the US Supreme Court cares
about knocking out a 100year-old plus
law? They just did it in Bruin. And yet
here you have DC saying, "Oh my god.
Oh my. We can't have a 100-year-old
statute knocked out. That would be crazy
talk even though the Supreme Court
literally just did it in Brun a couple
years ago. And yet here you have the
District of Columbia attorneys arguing
the reason why there needs to be onblock
review is to save a 100year statute.
Crazy talk. The next area where you see
they're playing games and games is they
claim that the divisions the the three
judge panels decision focused on a
weapons uh ubiquitousness in the
country. They then go on to say that
this speaks to Bruins step one, step one
of the brewin methodology. This is why
they don't want to talk about Heler
because Heler again once an arm is
covered by the plain text of the second
amendment, the burn shift to the
government to the historical analysis.
When you're dealing with a historical
analysis of an arms ban case, which this
is, this is a ban on magazines that hold
more than 10 rounds. It's also the
equivalent of a ban on firearms that are
capable of firing more than 10 rounds
without the need to be reloaded. Right?
So, it's either a arms ban case because
magazines are arms, which they are
because magazines are instruments that
facilitate armed self-defense. That's
the quote out of brein. And even if you
don't want to believe that argument, uh
there's another argument that's equally
good that points out that by banning
magazines that hold more than 10 rounds,
what you've done is you've banned an
entire category of firearms, firearms
that are capable of firing more than 10
rounds without the need to be reloaded.
And yet on page nine of this brief,
they're basically saying that the
weapons ubiquitousness u is essentially
the essence of step one, step one of the
second amendment, and that it's a
popularity contest. But that's
effectively that's wrong on several
levels. The first is again step one of
the brewin methodology which is really
just the Heler methodology in a paint by
numbers way. Brew and Heler are the same
methodology. You start with the plain
text of the second amendment. The right
of the people to keep and bear arms
shall not be infringed. We've already
discussed that a magazine is an arm. I
just explained why. It's either an
instrument that facilitates armed
self-defense and or goes with a gun. And
if you ban the magazine hose 10 rounds,
you ban firearms which obviously is an
arm. So now that this law implicates the
text of the second amendment, the burn
system of the government. Well, the
Supreme Court has already done the
historical analysis and concluded that
there is a historical tradition of
banning firearms in America, but it's
very narrow. It's only for those weapons
that are dangerous and unusual. And as
we've discussed before, if a particular
arm is not unusual, i.e. it's
ubiquitous, meaning it's everywhere,
it's very common, it's used by Americans
for commonly for lawful purposes, or
it's in common use by Americans for
lawful purposes, which these magazines
undeniably are. There's hundreds of
millions of these out there.
Well, it can't be banned. And keep in
mind, the reason why the anti-gunners,
and we've talked about this before, I've
done this in the Harvard Journal of Law
and Public Policy. I've done this in
speeches in front of judges. Um, I've
done this on the channel. I point out
that the anti-gunners are desperate to
try to move the income use test to the
plain text analysis because the burn of
proof arguably at the plain text
analysis of Heler and Breuan is on the
Second Amendment rights claimants. But
once the text is implicated, the burn
shifts to the government. That means
when you're dealing with an arms ban
case, whether it be a ban on AR-15s, a
ban on semi-automatic rifles, or a ban
on these magazines, guess what? The
burden is on the government to show that
that particular arm that they've banned
is dangerous and unusual. Which means,
by extension, the burden is on the
government at the historical level to
show that for example here, the
magazines that hold more than 10 rounds
are not in common use by Americans for
lawful purposes. And there is a zero 0%
chance that that can be established
because these things are are completely
everywhere uh owned by virtually all gun
owners. Hundreds of millions of them
owned by tens of millions of Americans.
They are as ubiquitous as you can get
when it comes to an item owned by
American. All right, folks. So, we'll
see what happens. I suspect the Trump
Department of Justice is going to file
an opposition brief. I presume Mr.
Benson's attorney is going to file an
opposition brief. uh we'll let you know
when that happens is a big deal folks
because if the DC court of appeals uh
denies onbank review then the next step
for DC to take if they are so willing to
do it is to seek cert from the US
Supreme Court and one wonders whether
they will do that or they will just take
their ball and go home and accept their
losses out of fear that they don't want
the Supreme Court to take this case
because the Supreme Court if they take
this case is almost certainly going to
rule for the second amendment and spank
these anti-gunners again the history of
the future is yet to be written so I'll
just keep you apprised as things
developed. Okay, there you have it. Hope
you enjoyed today's episode. Make sure
you follow me over there on X Forbboxin.
Don't forget to subscribe both the
YouTube and the Rumble. And I'll talk to
you again real soon here at the Bour
Boxes Diner.
>> Orders up. Table 2A.